how many bad kids today max I would pass
by any of our streets bad kids
to see max graduating
[Music]
irrationally here at Crestview we frown
upon physically assaulting the [ __ ]
students of course not good for you to
mix all of these personality types
together 10 months out of the years
no wonder students Fitz jealousy rage
paranoid delusion
honestly max it's a miracle they don't
all kill each other
[Music]
while pondering your erroneous wins the
six of you will write a summary on the
history of Crestview Academy and doors
will remain locked until I return
confident the six of you can survive an
entire eight hours right then I'll be
off
you can't let's get one thing perfectly
clear we're in detention yeah this is
not a lovin this is not feel-good
eighties movie of the year where for
seven hours we put aside our deaths and
through commiserating about our mutually
dysfunctional family lives or how lonely
our alienated
we bring some sort of common ground and
end up as BFFs spirit show us your
presence